in the lobby of Ramsey solutions David
and Vanessa are with us hey guys how are
you
we're doing great awesome welcome
welcome where do you guys live we live
right here in Franklin Tennessee
neighbors there yeah all right very cool
and here to do your debt-free scream
that's right just down the street very
cool how much dad have you paid off we
paid off $75,000 cool and how long did
that take um 12 months Wow very quick
and your range of income um started
about 120 um and ended about 150 Wow how
do you get that big arrays in 12 months
well David did get a raise but I went
back to work
oh there's that too okay very cool so
what kind of debt was the $75,000 that
you paid off I would be my husband's
grad school student loan there you go so
what's your grad degree in David I got
my MBA
oh good from where from Harvard oh good
for you
Wow muckety-muck Wow I mean the presence
of royalty here Wow good for you what do
you do for a living I'm a program
manager okay cool and what about you
Vanessa you said you go back to work
yeah well I'm a CEO mama
currently but over the last ten months I
was working as a dietician in a doctor's
office okay very cool good for you guys
so uh what kind of debts to 75 thousand
is all the student loan debt this was
all student loan debts Dave very cool so
you need to get Sallie Mae out of the
house that's right and what happened
twelve months ago that made you believe
you should and could do this yeah so we
did have this big student loan debt come
out of business school and in fact one
hundred and thirty thousand when we when
we first graduated we moved here we
bought a house and started living life
and we wanted to save for good things we
wanted to have retirement accounts we
want to save emergency fund college for
our kids
vacations pay off our house pay off our
student loans and we couldn't do it all
and we came to realize that we were just
treading water we were trying to put a
little bit of money everywhere and it
just wasn't getting us any anywhere fast
so we we read the Total Money Makeover
and it really resonated with us do you
have these baby steps to attack them one
at a time and put your focus on them and
actually get traction mm-hmm so about a
year ago we've been you know making
progress and we got down to where we
were
seventy-five thousand left and we said
you know I think if we really go for it
we can do this quickly and we had our
ten-year anniversary or wedding
anniversary was coming off so we said
all right by 10 years we want to be done
with this guy we also wanted our third
baby as you can see we're like let's get
this time for baby all right cool so
good reasons to go ahead and knock it
out just set a goal and hit it yeah and
so that you decide to turn up the heat
and go crazy at that point yeah okay so
it was the craziest thing you did in the
last 12 months well one of the craziest
things we did is we actually moved out
of our house and we rented it like a
furnished executive type rental as we
and we moved across the way in an
apartment so that we could like cash
flow and walk away you know how much did
that make you I mean it's probably
between probably six and eight thousand
dollars um it was we had the date set
like we wanted it done by our
anniversary and as we kind of got closer
we were like I don't know if we're gonna
make it what can we do to make up that
gap and we're like let's run out our oh
wow yeah so you were able to keep it
rented enough that it made sense huh
yeah yeah when we rented it for that you
know about five months straight oh okay
yeah over the summer all right very Nate
well you never know that's crazy that
that that's on the list it was crazy
yeah so um very cool so what was the
hardest part of this whole process for
you all in the last 12 months
other than being out of your house which
obviously was not easy yeah so what we
did we weren't able to take advantage of
the snowball very well since we just had
one giant debt yeah so we were we were
trying to figure out how do we stay
motivated over this time and so Vanessa
we put together a little thermometer
chart so we can track our progress well
we I remember reading about this when we
read totally
make a room like this is what we'll do
and you know when we had that set date
at the top and you know we got to do it
before the day so yeah I think that was
the hardest thing is like staying
motivated over the whole period I mean
we took Financial Peace University twice
oh wow
during that 12 months we just signed up
and graduate and then we signed up again
well that helps yeah that being in the
class really does it puts a lot of
positive people write a lot of positive
influence around you and people tell me
you can do this it's very possible and
all that kind of stuff
yeah the classes really helped us get
ghazal intents yeah so I've been kind of
taking baby steps towards the baby steps
and not want to really go all in
especially like I was getting to match
on the 401k right so I didn't want to
give that up
honey and right but really the classes
convinced us we've got to go for this
all in and once we stopped make it get
in the match at work I immediately was
way more motivated I went out a second
job
oh we just cut the budget to the bone
and that's when it really made sense
that if we follow the baby steps and get
gizelle intense you get you know
progress a lot faster you can break the
back of this thing yeah very cool very
cool
now you got two children and a third one
on the way right yep and what are their
names and ages um we got Avonlea using
five years old okay and then our three
year old Weston is running wild
somewhere okay and and then this baby is
due in three days
oh my goodness all right very cool all
right well good looking family you guys
congratulations we proud of you we've
got a copy of Chris Hogan's retire
inspired book number one bestseller
that's the next step is to copy for the
view of that for you because the next
step is to become very wealthy and
outrageously generous and obviously
you've changed your family tree
congratulations
thank you so all right has Avonlea been
practicing it all at five years old oh
yeah she knows how to do this oh yeah
all right looking forward to it good
David and Vanessa Avonlea in Weston
$75,000 paid off in 12 months making 150
120 to 150 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
a mango 3 2 1
guys very well done very well done I
love it I love it I love it excellent
very cool it doesn't get any better than
that folks hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show